es ist kurz vor mitternacht das hier ist
die raststätte am bonner verteilerkreis
in köln von hier aus geht es auf alle
autobahnen und ich bin hier verabredet
mit gentleman der geht von hier aus
gleich auf frankreich tour und mit
seinen nightliner dem tourbus kommt dann
gleich nochmal vorbei wir reden über
seine neue dvd gentleman the evolution
soccer city live
da gibt es intime einblicke in den
touralltag und wir werden auch im team
mal wird er gleich haben in seinen
nightliner da bin ich sehr gespannt wenn
er jetzt kommt dann ist jetzt vielleicht
hier um die ecke
hier ist der große meeting rollen für
die tour erst mal große begrüßen aber
wir werfen schon mal blicken muss
behalten sie lag die sensation bei dir
sensationell ich habe jetzt hier
ich mir eins ist ja ein trost passt
nicht immer ich es schön wenn was
schiefgeht aber ich habe gesagt wir
treffen uns am nightliner wir haben
schon heute genau verpassen ja das ist
es ja auch nach paris
das war
klasse da sind wir ja wieder ja wir sind
wieder im pazifik bei den frauen
der gerechtigkeit naja okay
wir haben genau machen mag
vielleicht hier in dieter unter unser
busfahrer
herrlich
wir dachten eigentlich machen wir führen
mit ihr durch nightliner aber dann habe
ich ihn kenne ich ja schon kennt sich ja
mal hutchins patrice hat uns den
haarklein gezeigt
das ist ja ein einmaliges projekt weil
ich erinnere mich als wir die reine
minow flip mino in die hand gedrückt
haben das ist so ein bisschen mit
entstanden die idee einfach unter euren
leuten diese mini kemmer kameras zu
verteilen oder ja das ist ja im grunde
diese tour film der drauf ist ist von
den flip cams gedreht worden und stephan
hatte halt die idee dann auch dass wir
uns gegenseitig filmen und das ganze
material leben sammeln und dann hat sich
der verein sich mit den apps jahr die
jungs zusammengesetzt und das
geschnitten ich finde es ist ein sehr
persönlicher film bei rausgekommen also
es ist jetzt wir wollten ganz bewusst
jetzt nicht in die philosophische tiefe
gehen ja ja dann ist es einfach nur das
was wir jetzt hier leben mehr
eingegangen die es gibt sind sehr
lustiger aufnahm es gibt im aufnahmen
von einem soundcheck irgendwie von den
hotels auf die man sich so freuen also
einfach so den zuschauer so ein bisschen
mit auf tour zu nehmen und ihn näher ran
zu lassen das war so die ambition bei
dem film dh die kameraleute wart ihr
alle selbst wie ihr mann kameraleute
ganzen und dadurch wird es ja
wahrscheinlich vermute ich ein wenig
intimer als wenn ihr so ein kamerateam
mit dicker kamera rumläuft oder das hat
so ein bisschen was von blair witch
project es wackelt die ganze zeit
okay das ist alles andere als
professionell
aber das macht er eben den charme auch
ausfindig und dann ist natürlich ist ein
konzert für das ist kein dokumentarfilm
ja obwohl er
jetzt in den kinos ausgestrahlt werden
wo ich schon gesagt dass die kinos
dieses gremium
hat sich dafür entschieden haben den
film gesehen und wollen ihn gern zeigen
der wird dann zwei tage lang laufen in
19 städten das ist auch für mich etwas
ganz neues wir haben
dann bei der premiere der beiden
verschiedenen städten und das ist schon
cool auch mal so das konzert vom summer
jam was ja der hauptteil der rolle ist
neben diesen kleinen tour film
mal im indischen kino zu sehen
das kann sich so auch noch nicht also es
ist ich bin froh auch das war richtig
viel frickel arbeit auch sotschi und
stefan heger haben das gemischt das ist
eine riesengroße mikrofon ehrung gewesen
so dass wir dann auch lesen also es war
einer echten aufwand so ich habe ja
selber nix für getan ich habe einfach
nur auf der bühne die musik macht aber
jetzt das endprodukt
das war richtig viele arbeiten und sich
auch noch meinen hut ziehen vor den
beiden mission vom thema her das ist
super geworden ich finde es klingt auch
richtig fett jetzt und das war nämlich
auch das ist ja nicht einfach so und es
sieht gut aus sieht sensationell aus
also die bilder vom festival sind auch
absolut beeindruckend und von wegen
keine arbeit ich habe gesehen du musst
schon einiges gemacht haben weil es hat
nicht geregnet aber du was na ja es war
die es war die heißeste nacht des jahres
und ich habe mich aber gewährt mein
manager erklärt auszuziehen
was du aber dann hätte auch keinen
großen unterschied gemacht es war glaube
ich um elf uhr abends haben wir gespielt
sie ihn angefangen bis halb zwölf und um
11 uhr war es noch so um die 40 grad das
war wirklich die heißeste nacht des
jahres oder ich glaube sogar der letzten
fünf jahre seit diesem super sommer 2005
also es war unfassbar heiß nach zwei
songs und irgendwie so dass man auf kurs
hätte machen können das war so aus
latsch im kiefer ich habe den eindruck
wenn ich so die ganzen bilder sehe
das ist also musik ist nicht nur etwas
was du abends machst du so nach dem
motto jetzt ist der freizeit vorbei ich
muss auf die bühne soundcheck auftritt
sondern da ist immer musik drin im
wahrsten sinne des wortes immer oder das
ist ein sieg für ja aber ist es
musik lebt ja auch von pausen ohne
pausen wer ist er nur krach ja gut das
stimmt der karten
deswegen sind die pausen eben auch
wichtig aber die pausen gehören genauso
zum musikmachen also auch diese diese
ruhephasen zwischendurch diese haben
diese zeiten des verarbeiten
was passiert so viele auch gerade auf
natur dass man oder bei einer
albumproduktion auch dass man einfach
diese zeit
wirklich nutzen muss um sachen zu
verarbeiten um wieder auch inspiration
und kraft zu kriegen und das gehört
genauso dazu wie selber auf der bühne
dann zu stehen und musik wirklich zu
machen deswegen aber ich glaube das
sieht man eben auch in dem in den kurven
oder man man kriegt es eben mit dass ein
gewisser ausgleich da ist das sport ganz
wichtig ist dass die disziplin auch
wichtig ist dass ein gesunder schlaf
wichtig ist und so das gehört halt alles
dazu also es wird echt eine menge dazu
um eben lange auf tour sein zu können
und so ist jetzt wieder auf tour ich
fange jetzt eine kurze pause und jetzt
geht es weiter bis zur pause und jetzt
geht es weiter diese floskel genau wie
beim fußball nach dem spiel ist vor dem
spiel die geht bei uns genauso könnte
durchaus hat aber nicht immer 90 minuten
gut könntest du ohne
also weiß ich nicht ob ich könnte ich
kann sie fragen immer schwer beantworten
ob ich könnte was wäre wenn und so aber
es ist einfach ein ganz wichtiger großer
bestandteil in meinem leben
musik zu machen nicht so
selbstverständlich geworden ohne dass es
jetzt eine routine ist sondern es ist
dem schlafengehen oder weiss essen nicht
merke bin ich lange kein kein song
gemacht habe oder mit der band gespielt
habt dann fange ich eigentlich leer zu
fühlen und
was ist dann wenn so was passiert
wenn das ein band gerissen ein band an
gelassen ich habe ich manchmal weiß ich
gar nicht ob es sinn macht da jetzt
immer nach dem sinn zu fragen auch
dieses ding ich habe immer gedacht alles
passiert für einen grund vielleicht
passieren manche sachen und auch
einfacher ohne in grün ja weil auch dass
dieser bandscheibenvorfall nach dem
bandscheibenvorfall
der bänderriss
aber ich kann ja sehen die bänder sind
kaputt ich kann jetzt nicht umspringen
aber die stimme ist da wir haben alle
tierischen bock musik zu machen sind
leidenschaftlich gerne auf tour und
wissen dass wirklich zu schätzen auch
mit der musik so weit herum zu kommen
auch jetzt wieder in diese europa tour
auch gerade in den balkan
balkan staaten wo wir wo wir spielen
werden also wir haben einfach
unglaublichen spaß und deswegen weiß ich
nicht es gibt immer wieder diese diese
brakes und manchmal kommen die halt so
ohne dass man sie plant ja meine tante
sagt er über weiß wofür es gut ist was
du ja auch hast du an kriegen lassen
vielleicht schreibe ich jetzt als
nächstes einen ganz ruhigen song oder
ein ganz wilden weil du innerlich models
oder keine ahnung vielleicht kommt
irgendwann irgendwas was spezielles
dabei aber wie gesagt ich mache mir ich
habe irgendwie angefangen wenn es womit
habe ich das verdient hab ich hab doch
keinem was böses getan wenn er schon
jemand der daran glaubt irgendwie das
alles zurückkommen jeder kriegt das was
er verdient und das leben ist ein
supermarkt und am ende kommt die kasse
und so aber da wusste ich echt nicht
also was ist in lugano hingegen ich habe
auch nicht das gefühl also es gab ja
schon mal diesen bandscheibenvorfall
oder dass man krank wird dass man sich
ausgelaufen da war hatte ich aber immer
das gefühl so das liegt einfach daran
vielleicht zu viel gemacht habe weil ich
nicht auf meine signale gehört habe war
ich total ausgelaugt war und trotzdem
immer weiter gemacht hat nur dieses mal
auch in der zeit ich habe das gefühl
haben ich war total mit mir den klang
ich ernähre mich gesund ich rauche nicht
ich trinke nicht ich bin vegetarier
geworden trotzdem passieren diese du
machst alles besonders gut und richtig
und dann der falsche weg ja du hast es
sich wieder saufen und drogen nehmen und
fleisch essen vielleicht ist es genau
dieses bewusst gutmensch sein wollen
vielleicht mag das der da oben nicht
aber das ist gar nicht so dieses bewusst
gutmensch sein wollen sie hören es ist
wirklich der auf ganz natürliche weise
gekommen
wir werden jetzt mit thomas die auch ein
gespräch und was so ein ding ist beim
wgt aber da gibt kommt nicht von
hölzchen aufs stöckchen aber ist ja so
ein bisschen so
warum ist man etwas wo ohne ende gemüse
rein gesteckt worden ist macht es ja
wissen können eigentlich
das ist so ich meine so eine ökonomische
ansatz mal warum nicht weiß wo was ja
weil die tiere die essen gemüse wir
können auch gemüse essen wir konnten ja
direkt essen ja eigentlich in allen
verschwendung
ist welches gerade
hier war es ja einfach so ein ding ich
wollte es einfach mal ausprobieren und
fühle mich gerade viel wohler damit ich
werde auch jetzt nicht sagen ich werde
nie wieder fleisch essen ich bin jetzt
auch nicht mehr mit erhobenen
zeigefinger und sagt wir könnten nur
aber ich bin schon oft in interviews
gefragt was machst du denn so für die
umwelt und musste dann wirklich
überlegen ich trenne keinen müll ich mag
auch gern autos und las auch mal das
licht an und so nicht gedacht okay ich
bin eigentlich nicht so der umwelt zu
über wohl hier eigentlich vom design her
da wo das eigentlich passen würde zu mir
und das beste was ich machen kann ist
kein fleisch zu essen ein allein was man
ja meist die gleiche industrie wie die
unsere erde kaputt macht dazu kam dass
ich jetzt meine fische mit einem ganz
anderen inneren ruhe angucken sich auch
kein fisch mehr essen und
einfach
nicht so viel leid in kauf nehmen will
für ein essen was ich auch anders wählen
kann aber es ist eine persönliche
entscheidung irgendwie aber ich glaube
schon jetzt reden wir doch lange drauf
haben ja dass wir eine bessere welt
hätten wenn wir alle vegetarisch essen
würden ich glaube auch in jeglicher
beziehung setzen wir einer meinung
louis den zu wirken
pikant
ist eine idee ich danke dir danke